so we did Brooks's la we did it rubes
and now it's time for Chicago the chili
City the Windy City the number one under
the Sun Room you showed me New York
Pizza welcome I'm gonna show you guys
Chicago pizza we're going to my favorite
pizza place ever in the world he loves
pizza
mai-chan right let's go
I can't not cheer if people are doing a
cheer okay let them reach me Claus is it
it's time for the ultimate showdown
welcome all to the main event
I think this is the moment of the trip
we've all been waiting for Chicago pizza
first New York Pizza well that's also
not forget about here's the place Pete's
a cheese lookey you love it what about
you I really like it more than you are I
need some more energy from you guys cuz
I'm gonna take you guys in my next
favorite place hey before we go I just
want to twist a little something to go
all right yo guys we are in Chicago go
weather is gloomy but that's just what
we do baby if it's booming the party the
party ain't stopping nope
one cow Podcast the best dim sum in
Chicago's Chinatown
this was my dude my number-one players
table back in the day
Ronnie Manor no pal component so this is
this is Al Capone's table this is his
corner he loved the shrimp dumplings Al
Capone's good looks Al Capone shrimp
dumplings me me me any
oh boy we might need a second table how
much did you order not enough what is
your technique for chopsticks I kind of
just qua really hard to but I know I'm
working hard to get it off alright guys
so we've done pizza we've done dim sum
it's dessert time yeah I'm taking you
guys to bang bang pots
bang bang pie literally these are the
best desserts ever created or engineered
by human being Wow Oh does it look
better does it look good it looks really
good alright so away we go
I guess I'll have to give bangs hey our
room
I got you the key lime pie because
you're super sweet and you also get a
little bit of an attitude I do
grouchy boy number one Brooksie boy I
got you the chocolate macaroon cuz
you're the number one back daddy thank
you and I got myself honey pie
cuz you are
I'm so full Thank You Joey no thank you
guys seriously man that was about the
bass I love your cities you guys are my
second with their best friends who's
number one la pizza oh it's so good